gleich zu beginn und freuen uns und sind
gespannt auf das gespräch mit diesem
mann diplom-psychologe eigentlich vor
allem aber ein echter computer crack
sprecher des chaos computer clubs den
wir fragen wollen wie ist es möglich
dass ein 20-jähriger dennoch zu hause
bei mama und papa wohnt ein handy
nummern adressen ausweise briefe der
kanzlerin kreditkartendaten von
bekannten persönlichkeiten und private
familienfotos von beispielsweise robert
a bekommt er sagt mich überrascht all
das nicht und man muss noch nicht mal
besonders viel können und man all diese
daten zu gelangen sagt einer der
beispielsweise auch die software für die
letzte bundestagswahl durchleuchtet hat
und der sagt diese software habe zu
testzwecken gehackt und sie waren
dermaßen schrottig dass man sich am ende
nur noch entsorgen konnte und wir fragen
wie kann das sein dass in einem high
tech land wie deutschland offenbar
wahlen so leicht zu manipulieren wären
fragen wir
linus neumann herzlich willkommen bei
uns in der sendung also zu den daten
sind die runde
mal ganz kurz ein geprüft bevor die
gleich über das sprechen was da passiert
ist diese diese software zur zur
bundestagswahl die wahl tatsächlich
solcher schrott dass man damit hätte
bundestagswahlen manipulieren können
hier also das ging los mit kollegen
martin schier sich der sich das mal
angeschaut hat und der klassische fehler
gefunden hat um in hessen mehr oder
weniger in der position zu sein alle
wahllokal daten die an dem an einem
zentralen server akkumuliert wurden dort
zentral zu ändern ist gar kein großes
problem der brauchte einfach nur so
passwörter wie test test und test der
wahlen ftp ftp fdp
und dann war das so weit dass er das in
hessen irgendwie quasi vollständig
manipulieren konnte und dann sind wir
haben uns zusammengesetzt auch noch mit
thorsten schröder und haben gesagt so
jetzt irgendwie jedes bundesland einzeln
zu hacken wer eigentlich ein bisschen
mühselig nehmen wir doch lieber einfach
die software und gucken uns die noch mal
an und dann haben wir da noch ein paar
monate drauf rum geforscht bis wir dann
am ende in der lage
auf vielfältigen wegen eigentlich alle
stimmen die mit dieser software
ausgezählt werden zu manipulieren ich
muss eine einschränkung geben
das wäre im zweifelsfall zwei drei
wochen später aufgefallen wenn dann noch
mal eine zweite kontrolle kommt also wir
hätten das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis quasi manipulieren können
das wäre dann aber irgendwie in dem fall
bei der wahl 20 17 weil die hab ich
kenne auch was so 14 tage oder drei
wochen später wäre dann erst dann
aufgefallen
2017 die wahl bei der republik fast
minister geworden wäre war das ein
anderes thema reden wir bei anderer
gelegenheit nochmal drüber
herr kubicki sagt sie überrascht dass
sie nicht gehackt worden sind nein ich
bin nicht prominenten doch
offensichtlich waren sie auch sind siege
hector nein das ist auch komplizierter
als bei denjenigen die freiheit mit
ihren passwörtern umgehen oder fast wird
da haben die man leichte nachspielen
kann also 12345 ist ja eine standard
geschichte oder den eigenen namen zu
verwenden nur den namen der ehefrau oder
der kinder ja was haben sie für
passwörter kubicki 666 oder ganze reihe
verschiedener pass würde ein qaly
sichern
die meisten kenne ich selbst gar nicht
das ist auch sicher wenn das wasser ja
das ist letztlich sogar sehr sicher
beispielsweise beispielsweise werden was
wir dann beim deutschen bundestag
mittlerweile von der it-administration
vergeben ich sehe da nur die schwarzen
punkte wenn ich mal gucken will man bei
einer kanzlei ist es genauso wir sind
deshalb besonders geschützt war
natürlich interessante mandate haben die
ja auch anfällig während für
entsprechendes gewinnung und da machte
es auch der systemadministrator das
heißt aber wenn sie wenn sie dann in
ihre privaten accounts rein wollen
welche passwörter benutzen sie dann
oder macht dass ihre frau auch aus
sicherheitsgründen einfach und das wäre
verteilt meine form eines amtlich
passwörter kennt das glaube ich ja mal
passieren aber in der tat ist das bei
uns gerade weil wir auch also man
welchen beruf heraus besonderer weise
objekte oder subjekte der begierde sind
schon ganz ordentlich gemacht sobald es
überhaupt geht das heißt sie sich
schützen das wirklich ganz bewusst um
ganz gezielt ja und die werden auch
regelmäßig die ende die passwörter
nur eine verweildauer von vier wochen
bis drei monate zu erneuern ist das
sozusagen der erste wäre das der
richtige schritt oder anders gefragt
hat sie das überrascht wie leichtfertig
offenbar auch auch spitzenpolitiker die
ja nun auch große verantwortung tragen
mit ihren daten umgehen wenn man sicher
die meisten accounts wieder geknackt
wurden waren private accounts also her
wo jemand anders in dem fall die
bundestagsverwaltung versucht irgendwie
zu einer besseren sicherheits praxis zu
zwingen
da sind die ist dieser angreifer jetzt
nicht reingekommen hat sich aber auch
auf diese einfachen privaten accounts
spezialisiert und da gehen leute
natürlich ich will nicht sagen achtlos
mit um meistens ist einfach ein bisschen
darüber wie einfach
quasi ein passwort zu erraten ist oder
wie verheerend es ist ein passwort zu
nehmen was überall gleich ist weich
machen sie machen sie es mal beispiel
also wie geht so wie funktioniert so
eine kette oder anders gesagt ich kann
einer der irgendwo in mittelhessen 20
jahre im zimmer oder im keller wo auch
immer sitzt an solche daten kommen ob
der bei mama im zimmer sitzt in
mittelhessen oder in den malediven das
ist egal was ist internet ja das geht
immer das ist das schöne dass deswegen
ist das internet für uns hacker so
interessant und so wie es aussieht
dieser angreifer hat jetzt keine
übermäßigen technischen schwachstellen
aus können uns laut aussage des bka hat
er auch keine schadsoftware zum einsatz
gemacht das heißt jetzt nicht leute mit
viren infiziert oder so sondern das ziel
von diesem angreifer war immer ich
brauche letztendlich das passwort oder
einen gleichwertigen zugang zu dem
account
und sie haben ja gerade auch schon sehr
elegant schon mal versucht so nach dem
passwort zu fragen
elegant war dass sich aber ich habe
machen sie es hundertmal dann wissen sie
wie elegante methode die fünf von
hundert mal ganz gut funktioniert ist
gar nicht so schlecht
in wirklichkeit wollen natürlich gar
keine chance haben also was für eine
möglichkeit nach dem passwort zu fragen
sie schicken einfach mal so eine e-mail
in der sie sagen hier ist es droht ein
ungemach wenn du nicht sofort jetzt hier
klickst und dich einloggen und dann geht
man auf eine seite da ist dann ein quasi
die gefälschte log in seite die sie
jetzt von facebook erwarten würden sieht
genauso aus ist auf einem anderen server
sie geben ihr passwort 12 3 1
und in dem moment gehört schon den
angreifern also man fälscht quasi den
login prozess sehr häufig muss man noch
nicht mal so weit gehen leute verwenden
einfache passwörter die sich beraten
lassen oder ganz verheerend überall das
gleiche
weil dann brauche ich ja nur ein county
irgendwann einmal zu knacken um dann zu
wissen wie das vieh im zweifelsfall das
passwort zu allen anderen leute und es
sieht danach aus dass hier eine reihe an
unterschiedlichen derartiger angriff
taktiken zum einsatz gekommen ist und
die personen mit denen ich bis jetzt
gesprochen habe die betroffenen waren
die haben dann auch mehr oder weniger
zähneknirschend zugegeben dass ihr
passwort wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht das
tollste war dass sie keine zwei faktor
authentifizierung genutzt haben
robert habeck zum beispiel kanzler 2009
10 ist kein gutes passwort
als beispiel ist kein gutes vor allem
jetzt nicht mehr jetzt bekannt ist also
jetzt sitzt da dieser 20-jährige und
trägt das alles ganz akribisch zusammen
das ist ja tatsächlich ein krimi von dem
sie aber trotzdem sagen man muss das
medial auch nicht so aufbauschen das ist
nicht der größte hacker angriff aller
zeiten sondern muss man genau hinschauen
da muss da operieren wie auch teilweise
mit begriffen die eigentlich miteinander
gar nichts zu tun haben mit wie würden
sie das beschreiben was da passiert ist
also erstmal muss unterschieden werden
wer wurde gehackt und wer wessen daten
wurden veröffentlicht daten wurden
veröffentlicht von ich glaube ungefähr
1000 personen waren seine zahlen
wirklich gehackt wurden um die 50 ist
sind die offiziellen zahlen
das heißt sicherheitsprobleme hatten
eigentlich nur diese 50 leute
es hat aber offenbar ausgereicht um die
persönlichen daten von vielen anderen
zusammen zu tragen
beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt hier herr
kubicki kennt sein passwort nicht
schlecht ist schlechtes angriffsziel
hätten wir sie ich finde es auch
meistens nicht aber ja hätten wir sie
werde gelingen gelangen darüber an ihr
e-mail-postfach an die personen mit
denen sie kommuniziert haben unter
umständen an adressbuch dann habe ich
natürlich schon mal die persönlichen
daten von sehr vielen anderen personen
aus einer vorwahl lässt sich dann
vielleicht auch noch eine adresse dazu
finden wenn man schon mal weiß die
persönliche telefonnummer ist darunter
und diese daten wurden von dem angreifer
offenbar über sehr langen zeitraum
zusammengetragen so akribischer
kleinstarbeit ja das ist eine ganze
menge arbeit drin dabei auch sehr stolz
darauf er wollte das ja auch der welt
mitteilen ja dass er diese arbeit
geleistet in einem adventskalender hat
er das gemacht originellerweise denn
auch als er war
erste angriffe sind glaube ich vier
jahre her der hat sich da so in zunächst
im youtube umfeld rumgetrieben und
offenbar unterschiedliche bekannte
youtuber gehackt die offenbar entweder
für ihn attraktiv an weil die bekannt
vorhanden oder weil sie irgendwas gesagt
haben was ihnen jetzt sind wir gerade
nicht passte weiß ich nicht hatte er
offenbar wurde er zitiert damit dass er
mit den äußerungen einiger politiker
nicht einverstanden war und dann
erstaunlicherweise ausgerechnet die fw
fd nicht gehackt hat was ist ihre
erklärung dafür
naja also man sollte sich vielleicht der
hatte wenigstens so 23 alibi daten von
der afg darunter mischen können um nicht
ganz offensichtlich zu machen wo
irgendwie seine politische gesinnung
oder oder einfach deswegen weil
alexander gauland vielleicht jetzt nicht
so wahnsinnig viel im netz unterwegs ist
ja dass aber gerade bei leuten die nicht
so viel im netz unterwegs sind ist es
eigentlich am ende einfacher sie zu
hängen
weil die ja dann auch ein berliner
vielleicht ein bisschen der umgang damit
fehlt oder einverständnis dafür fehlt
also da ist scheint schon so dass diese
partei da jetzt aus gründen der
sympathie aus irgendwelchen konten noch
mal wusste lasse wurde aber warum macht
jemand so was die psychologie dahinter
sie sagen der der will dass dann auch
präsentieren er ist auch stolz darauf
ist dass gleichzeitig dann auch der
wunde punkt wiederum also sie können als
erfolgreicher hacker entweder
erfolgreich sein oder berühmt dafür
sie wollen nicht beides das geht nicht
sie können nicht erfolgreich und berühmt
sein das geht auf dauer nicht gut und
das ist ja ich habe in dem zusammenhang
gesagt man kann entweder ein berühmter
bankräuber werden oder ein erfolgreicher
banker dass das kann sie wenn sie wenn
sie 50 banken ausbauen und den ball ganz
flach halten wenn sie 50 banken
ausrauben dann ist das schlechteste was
sie machen können sagen sie haben diese
50 banken herausgekauft ja es ist
richtig dass also der fehler ist oder
das problem besteht darin sie haben ja
bei jedem einzelnen dieser angriffe im
zweifelsfall vielleicht einen fehler
gemacht zum beispiel so ein fehler wie
ich hätte jetzt mal einfach mit dem
angriffsziel eine zeit lang und
verhandelt darüber ob ich den account
zurückgeben oder nicht oder ich zähle
anderen leuten davon was ich als
nächstes mache oder dass ich gerade mein
computer verbrannt habe oder sonstige
ist ja also das sind ja sehr sehr viele
klitzekleine fehler die insgesamt aber
mit 50 potenziert einfach ein sehr
klares bild ergeben und das ist dann der
grund warum man den noch relativ schnell
jetzt auch gekriegt hat es gibt auch
technische spuren die am ende den beweis
geliefert haben
soweit ich weiß sind ähnlich öffentlich
deswegen will ich da jetzt auch nicht
viel zu sagen aber ich glaube er hätte
sich sehr viel arbeit oder sehr viel
ärger sparen können wenn er sich dieses
etwas pubertäre gehabe gespart hätte
ganz grundsätzlich ist das etwas von dem
sie sagen das zeigt einmal mehr dass wir
zu leichtfertig mit unseren daten
umgehen
was ist mit den ganzen social media
accounts mit twitter mit facebook was
kann man machen was sollte man lieber
lassen also kurze kurze tipps ja über
ein anderes passwort verwenden machen
sie das passwort so lang wie der dienst
zulässt und zufällig so dass sie es sich
selber gar nicht merken können
so wie herr kubicki sowie herr kubicki
dann sammeln sie diese ganzen passwörter
diese sicher nicht mehr merken können
in einem passwort safe also in einer
verschlüsselten datei zu der sie dann
ein möglichst sicheres sehr langes
passwort haben
so haben sie jetzt also die situation
sollte ihn eines dieser passwörter mal
abhanden kommen sind wenigstens nicht
alle direkt verloren
sichern sie das e-mail-konto besonders
ab weil aus dem e mail konto lassen sich
alle anderen passwörter immer wieder
herstellen das ist auch das was hier
regelmäßig getan wurde
zumindest bei den personen mit denen ich
in kontakt stehe dass der angreifer sich
hat das e-mail-konto geschnappt hat und
dann einfach facebook twitter usw
die passwort
wiederherstellungsfunktionen ausgelöst
hat um so wieder anders okay das heißt
schreibt die dann quasi also ich hab
mein passwort vergessen da das bieten ja
viele plattformen ja auch an und
schicken die dann neues verlieren so
viele leute ihre passwörter
facebook könnte ja gar nicht mehr
operieren wenn sie mit jedem einzelnen
dieser person telefonieren würden da
gibt es einfach knopf schicken wir mal
ein link an meine e-mail-adresse ok und
wenn man dann auf diesen link klickt
dann kann man ein neues passwort setzt
das heißt der die ware sensible stelle
ist der e mail account und das ist auf
jeden fall der wichtigste account den
den personen so haben dann die nächste
schwachstelle sind was gibt es überhaupt
für methoden die passwörter
zurückzusetzen teilweise ich hoffe dass
das nicht mehr viele dienstanbieter
machen aber es gibt so was wie du hast
ein passwort vergessen sagt mal bitte
den geburtsnamen deiner mutter relativ
einfach herauszufinden
dein lieblingstier da gibt es nur 20 25
im zoo der lieblingstiere und dein
geburtsdatum ja und zac hat man so eine
counter alles über wikipedia von deren
kubik und diese schnell rauskriegen als
beispiele ärgerlich natürlich auch
geburtsdatum wird
also fragt steht dann gerne mal irgendwo
im stelle gerne mal ihr wohl in
wikipedia keiner weiß woher kam die
weibliche des bundestags dann gehen sie
als nächstes hin und aktivieren wo es
geht die zwei-faktor-authentifizierung
bedeutet man kommt nicht mehr nur mit
dem passwort rein sondern braucht noch
einen zweiten faktor der in der regel
sich aus haben oder sein zusammensetzt
also ich habe ein mobiltelefon oder sein
wird häufig realisiert über so
biometrische faktoren lassen wir das mal
ganz kurz weg das führt am ende nur noch
zum größten und frieren aber wenn sie so
was haben sie kriegen sms nochmal den
code zugesehen und müssen den auch noch
mal reden
das heißt der angreifer hat automatisch
jetzt zwei hürden zu überwinden er muss
ihre sms empfangen und er muss das
passwort kennen solche kleinigkeiten die
im leben im alltag nicht besonders
wehtun können da eben am ende diejenigen
unterscheiden die vielleicht nur mit
einer telefonnummer adresse und die e
mail adresse in so einem leak auftauchen
von denjenigen von denen dann am ende
persönliche daten e-mails
personalausweis pass kopien oder sowas
da liegen übrigens auch alle denken wo
kommt die bekommt der scan von den pass
her weil am ende denken sie kurz nach
wann ihr travel agent oder irgendjemand
sie das letzte mal nach dem scan ihres
passes gefragt haben die kommt im
zweifelsfall einfach aus dem gesendet
ordner ihres e mail postfach
das heißt dass de mail account ist
eigentlich die wirklich sensible stelle
in der kanzlerin da geht's auf jeden
fall los e-mail-account geht es los und
wenn man den zwei faktor gesichert hat
einzigartiges passwort gesichert hat
dann kann man anfangen sich über den
rest gedanken zu machen und da muss man
ganz systematisch vorgehen
unterschiedliche passwörter setzen die
alle sammeln aufpassen dass man wenn der
anbieter so etwas mit diesen einfachen
wiederherstellungs fragen macht dass man
dort eben falsche antworten gibt also
nicht nicht nur inhaltlich falsche
sondern eben auch einfach eine
geschichte dazu passenden ja also nicht
nicht einfach ein anderes tier sagen und
sagen hh
sondern halt kein tier sondern einfach
ich habe 16 zeichen für ein tier also
nämlich 16 zufällige zeichen das ist
jetzt das tier wie ist der name ihrer
mutter angela merkel geben wir dann
einfach an den zukunft das wäre ja so
eine idee ich würde alles immer mit so
lang wie möglich und so zufällig
dann fasst angeregt kramp karrenbauer
dann wieder an dem punkt aber jedes mal
wenn jedes passwort passiert gesagt
haben nicht mehr das kann es ganz
schlecht
ok obertan reagiert jetzt finde ich sehr
sehr hart darauf und sagt ich melde mich
einfach ab twitter weg facebook-account
weg wie finden sie das
also facebook finde ich sehr sympathisch
das sollte niemand machen weil nicht
wenn sie das ist ein unternehmen was
ihre persönlichen daten alles was ihr da
rein kippen auswertet mit dem einzigen
ziel ihn nachher irgendwelche werbung zu
präsentieren
da habe ich einfach auch mit meinem
leben was besseres anzufangen als meine
daten so einem unternehmen das machen
alle anderen ja auch ne das mag ihr
alphabet oder google das macht instagram
das machen die alle ich denke facebook
ist natürlich einfach also instagram gut
gehört facebook ist ja nicht gehört für
mich in der gleichen laden andere
unternehmen oder andere soziale
netzwerke haben wenigstens noch so eine
schöne limitation in ihrem
anwendungsfall ja also twitter ist du
möchtest etwas in die welt
hinausposaunen zum beispiel dass du der
größte hacker der welt bist und gerade
unsere kritische präsident aller im
bereich von der ja oder der größte
präsident aller zeiten
vielleicht hatte dorothee bär da gar
nicht so unrecht mit ihrer einschätzung
dieses netzwerkes politiker journalisten
und psychopathen
ich würde dann hoffen noch als
journalist zu gelten
[Gelächter]
gegen sie haben sie gemerkt
aber facebook wählen sagt führe auch
private kommunikation immer dieses
netzwerk ja schreibe direktnachrichten
mit deiner familie verraten deine
freunde in bildern indem du sagst das
ist ja ja also wenn das die hamburger
polizei macht über die bild zeitung dann
regen wir uns zu recht darüber auf wenn
ein sozial an ein soziales netzwerk
tschuldigung in ein soziales netzwerk
uns dazu auffordert unsere freunde in
bildern zu brandmarken dann finden wir
das super und machen alle mit also das
sollte man wer sich um seine
persönlichen daten sorgt der ist
natürlich bei so einem unternehmen nicht
gut aufgehoben
dann ist es erstmal grundsätzlich so ein
politiker der jetzt sagt ich möchte eine
reichweite haben ich möchte vielleicht
auch mal kurz das geschehen kommentieren
der wäre unter umständen natürlich muss
er sich fragen ob er jetzt vielleicht
nicht das kind mit dem bade ausschütten
und die lache ich doch lieber sich
bemüht ein bisschen rat anzunehmen von
leuten die sich damit auskennt gibt es
hier ein paar wie man so ein account
vielleicht sicher betreibt denn es ist
ja immer noch so dass die meisten leute
nicht gehackt wurden
und das heißt weil sicherheitssysteme
offenbar doch auch funktionieren es ist
in der regel bei den meisten angriffen
muss ich tatsächlich sagen so sehr mich
die technischen angriffe viel mehr
interessieren
also diese menschlichen angriffe sind
ein interessantes feld wenn man wirklich
ein bösartiger angreifer ist was sicher
nicht bin ich versuche meinen tag damit
umzubringen schwachstellen zu finden mit
dem ziel dass sie danach weg sind und
freue mich dann die welt ein bisschen
besser gemacht zu haben und vor allem
abends auch ruhig schlafen zu können
weil ich nicht irgendwie von mama
computerverbot kriege weil ich wieder
scheiße gemacht habe im internet ja wenn
man
in den kriminellen bereich geht dann
funktionieren dort die angriffe meistens
auch mit einer menschlichen komponente
dass irgendwo mal jemand gefischt wird
also mit einer falschen seite dazu
gebracht wird sein passwort einzugeben
dass menschen fehler machen bei der auch
bei der vergabe ihrer passwörter oder
das wenn man jetzt zwei antworten weiß
man braucht um dort das geburtsdatum
dann kann man auch einfach mal anrufen
fragen ja sagen sie wir müssen ganz kurz
ihre daten besteht hingegen eine
kurzzeit menschliche komponenten spielen
bei den meisten großen angriffen eine
rolle so übrigens auch bei den fans
immer mehr angriffen die mehrere
unternehmen lahmgelegt haben da hat ja
auch ein mensch eine e mail geöffnet die
eigentlich dubios war gut oder schlecht
gefälscht aber auf jeden fall ein köder
sie zu öffnen und diese menschlichen
komponenten
die werden wir im zweifelsfall nicht los
und als psychologe mache ich mir
natürlich gedanken darüber wie wir
bessere systeme für die
authentifizierung für die anmeldung für
die sicherung unserer systeme finden
können die nicht anfällig sind für
unsere eigenen schwächen wie passwort
1234 weil das gleiche passwort zu
verwenden so und nochmal abschließend
gefragt also dieser 20-jährige der
verdient ja kein geld damit
damit verdient man ja nichts mehr hat
der den ihrer szene sagen sie ist das
auch nichts womit man groß so sagen
ruhm und ehre ernten könnte warum macht
er das also in der szene aus der ich
komme gibt es einen ganz kleinen
grundsatz öffentliche daten nützen
private daten schützen
wer sich unseren ethischen prinzipien
verbunden fühlt würde sich an solchen
maßnahmen nicht beteiligen und ich denke
da spreche ich für den sehr sehr großen
teil des chaos computer clubs wäre so
etwas nicht tun
es gibt eine ganze reihe an motivation
die ich natürlich auch in meiner
sozialisierung als hacker durchgemacht
habe wo man vielleicht zu läuten
aufschauten vielleicht auch ein falsches
verständnis davon kommt
was jetzt irgendwie ein coolen hacker
ausmacht auf jeden fall gerade in dem in
so jungen jahren versucht man ja
irgendwie auch ruhm und ehre zu bekommen
von mir aus irgendwie pseudonym andere
gehen hin und sprühen irgendwelche namen
an jede wand und den tod in
zweifelsfällen am ende auch leid für
diese nahmen diesen ruhm und ehre
gesammelt zu haben was diese offenbar
freude daran angeht diesen menschen auch
in der öffentlichkeit in dieses leid
zuzufügen
das kann ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen
ich habe mit einigen der betroffenen von
diesen angriffen kontakt und kann nur
sagen dass wir menschen auch wirklich
nicht antun
es wäre eine sache vielleicht politisch
motiviert sagen wir mal eine politikerin
oder einen politiker zu hacken gezielt
den das postfach durch zu stöbern und
vielleicht einen politischen skandal am
ende zu offenbaren das wäre irgendwie
eine sache wo man unter umständen am
ende irgendwo vielleicht noch eine
ethische ebene zu finden kann aber dann
auch noch gezielt auf die privaten
accounts zu gehen um auf die kinder
zugehen das ist halt ich glaube es wäre
gut gewesen wenn der junge mann viel
früher die aufmerksamkeit bekommen hätte
nach der es ihm ja hier irgendwie
gedürstet hat jetzt hat er die
aufmerksamkeit
ich glaube das system jetzt auch nicht
so recht und hoffen dass er vielleicht
irgendwie offene in zukunft einfach
andere wege auch findet für sich selber
im technischen bereich und im
heckbereich was zu finden sich ja
irgendwie motivieren oder dunklen seite
der macht auf die andere zu wechseln das
wäre doch mal eine idee
[Applaus]